The answer here is that the shortest path from A to B
that visits all vertices has length 19,
so 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, and so on. You can recount if you don't trust me by now.
The number of shortest path from A to B, that again is 2.
So having these 2 possibilities of a shortest path
that visits all vertices from A to B either going this way or going this way.
That is in some way very similar to setting a variable to true or false, isn't it?
Because, if I want you to go from A to B as quickly as possible
while visiting all vertices, then there are only 2 choices that you have.
The interesting thing is that, in one of those choices
you always take the edge that goes from bottom left to top right,
so this one here, this one here, this one here, and so on.
If you start out by going down right, then this is what you will do
at any other edge here as well.
There's no shortest path between A and B that mixes up these 2 possibilities,
so that takes some of these edges here and some of these edges here,
and this is exactly what we're going to use to represent a variable
being set to true or false.